[Music]
on your knees
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
we're thieves but we help the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blade because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
follow me to the orifice
the orifice
I'll go lost
I don't mind that
she missed
no that's not good
what you're sick of failing we couldn't
die there's worse things than dying
I lost everything that ever mattered to
me and if we quit now that's for nothing
I don't want to see you die which is why
I'm Gonna Leave the Room
this ends now
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
truth be told
we help the wrong person steal the wrong
thing
we didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink
you need to give us a fighting chance
we're gonna need strength you got this
right I know you don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's now there
[Music]
they want
there is evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this I'm
a planner I make plans you've already
made some plants so the existing plan
fails I make a new plan so you make
plans that fail no he also plays the
loot not relevant
[Music]
oh I got a good feeling about this
dungeons of dragons is that classic
hero's journey we've got a ragtag group
of Misfits Where we have to fight
dragons and evil wizards in order to
save the world well how do we pull that
off uh figure it out over a drink
probably best
it's about finding your own hero within
and each character has their own version
of that Journey oh got him now
is it exactly that you bring for this
I'm a planner I make plans I will not be
complicit in the Unicity of Seville
Gotham booty can someone else ride next
to this guy I think as a wicked sense of
humor through this and that allows us to
have as much fun with this as we can
I'm glad he's on our side the nuances
that each individual actor brings is
what makes this film so great
this I give you now trusting that you
look protected with your very life
I will
hold this
[Music]
I'm part of the ruthless sand of Thieves
but he's not as evil as the red Wizard
never put your trust in a con man
The Dungeons and Dragons World has
amazing creatures in this one I think
they outdid themselves
these creatures are the same you really
can tell they put a lot into this what
is that again now there
[Music]
this is just big fun movie making
it's a great adventure for characters
that you're going to care about we want
to give them the movie that they've been
hoping for that's what I've been saying
it's pretty badass
[Music]